right now election workers are
recounting votes in a razor thin race
for clark county commission district c
democrat and former secretary of state
ross miller beat republican
las vegas city council member stavros
anthony by just 10 votes in the november
election
our bianca holman is live at clark
county election headquarters with a
closer look at this process hi bianca
this will be one of the busiest days for
the recount election staff will be
recounting the in person
and early voting in-person ballots
throughout the day
now here's what happened anthony had a
lead election night but that lead was
gone when the mail-in ballots were
counted
eventually ross miller would win by just
10 votes
the county certified the vote last week
that's despite election officials saying
they identified 139 voting discrepancies
in the race
including some cases where people
possibly voted twice
for a while it looked like there would
be a complete re-vote in clark county
district c
but that didn't happen and the county
commission certified the totals
one reason this race is so closely
watched is not just because of the slim
vote margin
anthony is hoping to be the first
republican elected to the clark county
commission in
16 years joe gloria the clark county
registrar
says that everything was read in for the
general election
last month will be taken off the shelf
and counted again
we've got it counted exactly the same
way that we counted ballots
leading into the election the difference
is we don't have to wait for the county
board to do work
the ballots are basically prepped
because they've already been through the
county board process and been counted
one time
so we can move at a much brisker pace
now any candidate is able to call for a
recount which anthony did last week his
campaign says this recount effort will
cost 80 thousand dollars
gloria tells us the mail-in ballots will
be counted throughout the remainder
of this week and then we should have a
final report on friday
reporting from cheyenne mlk bia
oklahoman 8 news now